the State Department just revealed that
one American is among those killed in a
pair of terror attacks in Spain people
in Barcelona pause for a minute of
silence this morning to remember victims
of the deadly attacks afterward the
crowd erupted in applause to show
solidarity with those killed and injured
the death toll is now 14 after a woman
died this morning of her injuries in
Campbell Spain the rest were killed in
Barcelona when a van mowed down
pedestrians on a major boulevard more
than 100 were injured the victims come
from two dozen countries police have
killed five suspects and arrested four
others but the driver of that van in
Barcelona is still at large
Debora patta is in Barcelona with new
eyewitness accounts but first Seth Doane
is in Canberra where police killed the
five suspects after a second car attack
last night Seth good morning
good morning we were stopped at a number
of police checkpoints on our way down
here all part of that massive manhunt to
try to find at least one terrorist who
is still on the run
police say terrorists had planned a wave
of attacks gunfire was heard from inside
a Campbell's bar early this morning
outside police had shot dead five
attackers after they drove a car into
pedestrians in this coastal community
one of those wounded later died
Oh everybody was running Fitzroy Davies
witnessed the police operation and
captured these images on his cell phone
he then fell down and then within two
seconds you stood back up he then
stepped over the fence charged the
police again and the police then
[Music]
suspects wearing suicide vests he said
those vests were detonated by a bomb
squad and determined to be fake
authorities say the attack here in
Canberra 'ls was linked to the one in
Barcelona which unfolded just eight
hours earlier the attackers in that
truck jumped the curb at the busy Las
Ramblas in the heart of Barcelona
plowing into pedestrians those injured
and dying were left bloodied and
scattered along the street popular with
tourists
it had zigzagged for seven blocks
apparently trying to hit as many people
as possible the driver of the van was
seen escaping on foot
this man briefs oh Kabir has been linked
to the hiring of the vehicle and was
questioned by police but the driver
remains at large and Spanish media
report it could be his brother Musa Qala
Catalunya is police chief said both
incidents were carried out by a terror
cell of at least eight people who had
been planning the attacks for some time
and linked them to an explosion
Wednesday which leveled a house and was
originally reported simply as a gas
explosion
Isis has claimed responsibility for
these attacks CBS News has learned that
it might not just be a text inspired by
Isis but perhaps carried out by Isis
itself as you can see people here are
just stunned at this idyllic beach
community wondering how something like
this could happen all right Seth Doane
thank you reporting from Canberra does
that mean we'll talk about that